welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin in Hong Kong today barely one
week after the 30th anniversary bursary
rather of the Tiananmen Square massacre
the world is starting to focus on
another massive public protest by young
people in China this time it is in Hong
Kong where police teargas protesters
overnight take a look at that the
demonstrations began over bill that
would allow extradition to mainland
China now opponents say this is part of
Beijing's push for greater integration
with the mainland and violates the
territory's separate status ramie nco is
in Hong Kong in the middle of the
protest good morning what started off as
a peaceful protest here in Hong Kong has
devolved into an ebb and flow of
protesters here and police on that side
chaos came quickly as demonstrators
refused to disperse and police fire tear
gas rubber bullets and water cannons
everyone in this area was hit including
us
we've just fit pepper-sprayed we've just
been teared asked by the police you can
see those bullets the hitting of people
that we were in a group with the staff
demonstrators had wanted to keep today
peaceful the hope to stop lawmakers from
debating the city's controversial
extradition bill the fear if passed
anyone here could be extradited to
mainland China what did the people here
think about China's legal system they
don't believe in China's legal system
and there's no fair trial and it's not
open people simply disappear if the bill
is successful it'd be retroactive to
past crimes
and would include foreigners if I'm an
American and I did something bad here I
could potentially be extradited to China
well you don't even have to do anything
bad what is just stop China from making
up evidence and protesters today have
actually successfully stopped the
Legislative Council from debating the
extradition bill but looking ahead this
could be a very short-term wind reason
for that is because the chief executive
Terry LOM has said that she will get
this bill through no matter what
Ramey Inocencio for CBS this morning
Hong Kong
[Music]